[Music]
lbc news time 6 31 it's chris golds with
you here
live across the uk uh this thursday
evening we're on
dab digital radio on your smart speaker
and on global player of course
um the fuzzy 100 has ended the
penultimate day of trading this week in
the red down 41 points at 65.26 we'll
find out where it opens with
lisa aziz at about eight o'clock
tomorrow morning she is of course
live uh on breakfast from six
now uh if you've been on social media uh
over the last 24-48 hours or so you will
have seen this story but
maybe you've been slightly confused by
it i know i have
and it's market regulators in the us
that are going to review this rally and
shares of the struggling retailer
gamestop following an
internet campaign stocks have risen over
1700 in the past couple of weeks mostly
driven by users of the social media
platform reddit
they were trying to show how easy it is
to manipulate the system
confused well let's try and break it
down for you here on lbc news i'd like
to say i'm joined by
gary stevenson who joins us now he's an
ex-city trader and is now an economist
uh
evening to you gary hi chris so what has
gone on here what sparked
it why gamestop what's going on give us
a detail
okay so first give you a little bit of
background the us is obviously going
through a very similar massive covid
epidemic like we are
a lot of people lost their jobs a lot of
people lost incomes a lot of people are
sitting at home unable to work and the
government's been sending out stimulus
checks to support these people
now at the same time the u.s stock
market has been on an absolute surge
it's nearly doubled in the last
um nine months and some stocks like
tesla have gone up nearly six times
other things like bitcoin absolutely
exploding so we've got a load of people
sitting at home
they can't work they're not making any
money um at the same time the richest
people in the country like jeff bezos
the value of their companies are
doubling and this is on the back of 10
years of stock markets exploding in that
country
so people at home are starting to think
listen i'm not happy with this thing
work isn't working for me
i'm not making any money and the super
rich are just getting super rich on the
stock markets and they want to get
involved
so they're surging onto the internet and
they're going through this website
reddit
which is a social media site it's a
message board site
there's an area on there called wall
street bets that's where people go to
talk about how to make money on the
markets what stocks to buy this kind of
thing
and some people came up with the idea
about gamestop so what you need to
understand about gamestop
is there's a big hedge fund with a few
hedge funds that decided that this was a
weak
company they decided to try and push the
stock price down by
short selling it so you need to know a
little bit about short selling all right
so to short seller stock
normally if you think a stock price is
going to go up you buy it but how do you
make money for stock price is going to
go down
well the way you do is you borrow the
stock for example a week for a week
for someone who has it and then you sell
it hoping to buy it back later at a
lower price
now these um hedge funds has shortened a
lot of this stock and some people
already figured it out so they said look
if we all go together and we buy loads
and loads of this stock we can push the
price up massively
we'll refuse to lend out any of the
stock for the short sellers and then the
short sellers will have to
buy the stock back when their loans of
their stock run out that means we can
push the price up and then the hedge
funds will have to buy a massively high
price and will make loads of money
now this is a thing which is relatively
well known historically in financial
markets it's called a short squeeze
you push the price up so that all the
shorts get lose loads of money and they
have to buy the higher prices
it was a massive short squeeze in the
gold market for example in the 80s
sometimes it's called cornering the
market they've even been guys who've
done this with sort of food markets like
wheat we're going to buy all the wheat
and the people who need them are going
to charge exorbitant prices
so basically amazingly this
horde of sort of unrelated people who
were sitting at home trading on the
internet
managed to push game stuff up 1500
in about two weeks which was phenomenal
that caused this uh one hedge fund i
think it's melvin is the name to
almost got bankrupt they lost about i
think 30 of their assets under value
um i mean it really is a phenomenal
story but i think what this tells you
is people are starting to
to this situation where the way we deal
with crisis is to bail out the stock
market
but not to bail our ordinary people and
people want to get involved
but i mean the way it's played out has
been really phenomenal my big concern
now is
and i think i would like to tell people
listening at home yeah really be careful
before you get involved in things like
this because
it is inevitable in my opinion i think
most market professionals would agree
that this stock will collapse back down
at some point
and uh some people are going to make a
lot of money on this you know there's
someone
on this radio website who claims to turn
fifty thousand dollars into 47 million
dollars
yeah if you get involved now that's not
going to be you and at some point this
is going to collapse and some people are
going to be holding it so i was just
really not of caution to people
listening don't rush in and get involved
in this
now my strong recommendation do you
think this is going to spark some sort
of trend
but it's already a trend i mean look at
bitcoin look at tesla look at that i
mean
the thing is you need to understand what
is happening with regards to the
coronavirus crisis government's all over
the tesla's not
tesla's stock's not going up because um
lots of people
are chatting about it on reddit they're
going up because they are
i've been on this website these guys
tested i mean listen i'm not an expert
exactly on
tesla
yeah i mean it's very very expensive
compared to other car makers and there
is a huge like i go on this i've been on
this
you know i trade markets and i look at
this website they love tesla they love
elon musk oh you know not all of them
but
if elon musk tweets something that will
move you know these guys they look at
that guy and um
the fact is you know governments have
printed lots of money
that's how they've dealt with this
crisis and that means there's a lot of
money spilling about in the system and
largely
it's ended up with richer people here
and if you give a lot of money to a lot
of rich people
they're going to buy stocks and i think
what's relevant to the uk they're going
to buy houses as well and you know we're
starting to see in the middle of
the worst economic crisis in our
lifetimes house prices are going up at
record pace
what do you think is going to happen
sorry what do you think is going to
happen to um gamestop themselves
i mean the company up the um that the
hedge funds which looked at this company
they they analyzed it to be a weak
company i mean i'll tell you one thing
they've definitely got a lot of free
advertising and publicity over the last
few days which will
probably support the company but um if
we assume and i think it is likely that
this stock price will simply rise and
fall
that doesn't actually really benefit the
company themselves it's purely a game
between
people who hold the stock the short
sellers and and this army on ready
essentially
um you know the company gets some free
advertising but
it was judged by many hedge funds to be
a weak stock it's trying to
compete with the massive giant like
amazon but realistically
presuming the stock falls back down it
doesn't really change the outlook for
the company itself
um do you think we'll see a move away
from stock markets and
how they work and how um massive what
you know massive part that they play
in um in you in their country's
economies or
or is this the model that is going to be
around for a while well i mean already
there's such a divergence between
countries economies and the stock market
i mean
just look at what's happened since 2008
you know the uk stock market's up i
think two or three times in that time
the u.s is up even more
stock markets just seems to go up and up
and the reason for this is
and this is another thing that these
guys already love to talk about is
whenever there's a strong economy stock
markets go up but whenever there's a
weak economy
central banks print billions of dollars
and that pushes stock markets up so it
creates a situation
where it feels like stock markets can
only go up whether it's a strong economy
or a weak economy
and what that means is whether workers
and ordinary families do well or badly
the rich always do well
so if that's the situation and if we
look at the last 12 years that seems to
be the situation
you can kind of understand why now
ordinary people are surging in
to buy these stocks well fascinating
talking to you i think you've made us
made uh some sense of all those memes
and various different videos i've seen
online so thank you very much for
joining us here on lbc news that's there
gary stevenson
an ex-city trader and an economist this
is lbc news the headlines are next
lbc news
[Music]